hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back on foreigner again and today
this video is gonna be talking about how
to get the event loot the fastest in the
new assassin's creed event for the creed
so as always like the VP do enjoy
subscribe if you're new I covered the
informational site a foreigner that
being balanced changes here are updates
patch notes and leaks as well some
guides as well but let's keep everyone
in the loop on what's happening in the
world before honor and with that let's
get started with today's video so real
quick if you have no clue what this
event is or you're missing out on a few
details you can click the I on the top
right there should be popping up right
about now if you click that link you'll
be taken to my video from yesterday and
that will show you all the new stuff on
what's happening in the new assassin's
creed event before the creed so just in
case you're unaware of what's happening
you can always click that video but this
event comes with a whole lot of things a
mask outfit a battle outfit elite
outfits emotes effects executions
embossing ornaments and weapons so
there's a lot of [ __ ] that's in here but
only a few of these things can actually
be looted the other stuff you have to
buy for example the things that can be
eluded are the battle outfit the effect
be embossing the ornaments and the
weapons the elite outfits are a little
bit of a throw up because you can
actually buy them for seven thousand
still but according to the description
you can actually scavenge these so I
might want to hold off on those before
the end of the event and if you do
really want to get those you can
definitely get those as well and also
another quick tip to remember that the
embossing are only available in the
arcade mode and in the new game mode
that just came out with this event so
you can only get the embossing from
those two game modes and as well
remember that if you don't get any of
this masks outfit emote effect execution
embossing ornament weapons etc any of
this if you not buy these or find these
within the event before the event is
over you will never be getting these
again and they would disappear forever
if you do get these than you will keep
them of course but if you do not get
them you can never get them again until
the next time they run this event back
which will probably be never well
finally to get into the actual question
of what is the best game-mode to do the
best game-mode to get the most loot is
Arcade Mode now I know what you're
saying some of you may not have arcade
mode we'll get to you in a second but
for the individuals that do have Arcade
Mode it is easily the best thing to do
there's going to be four different types
of chapters you have to get through the
first one is going to begin stay
peacekeeper where she does decent damage
but as her health bar lowers she's going
to be doing a lot more damage just parry
her move she's really not too hard the
light attacks will be a bit of an issue
but it shouldn't really be too hard
there's really not much I can help you
with since it's all based off of your
skill this
someone is gonna be against a warden
that has hyper armor on every single
move and all of his moves are
unblockable and you're probably thinking
that you should be parrying problem is
that you were given a debuff that you
cannot parry it which sucks but
thankfully all you have to do is if you
have hidden stance like JJ or Nobu Shi
you're in luck very easy
jugo kiki knew this pretty well with the
trading of hyper armor and as well any
character with a good dodge attack will
do very well with this specific chapter
now sadly if none of this fits into the
category of your character that you play
you're not totally out of luck it's just
going to be a little bit hard to fight
them but this really shouldn't be too
hard the next one is by far the easiest
you want to be one a gladiator the only
downside is that you don't have any
guard UI it's like you're playing
realistic from the campaign but the
gladiator does he drains your stamina a
lot more has a lot more damage on
blocking and attacks deal less damage so
that's a good debuff for him really
shouldn't be too hard this is probably
the easiest one so I really have nothing
else to say for this and then the last
one is against a Centurion who deals a
lot more damage has a lot more health
and when his health is even lower he
does even more damage very similar to PK
except with a lot more health so pretty
difficult
the only drawback for you is that you
deal less damage but it really shouldn't
be too hard just parry because most of
the the Centurion will throw is heavies
and lights they're very leave in charge
so just don't get caught up in his mix
ups always make sure to just be aware of
if he's going to guard break you and
stuff like that once again this is a
very easy quest and eventually you will
get all the rewards now I personally got
7 rewards from this which is absolutely
mind-boggling I'll show it on the screen
now so honestly this is a really good
way to do it and especially the more
that you do this more and more you'll
actually be more accustomed to it and
you'll get this done in three to four
minutes and very quickly but that is
going to be for the people that have
Arcade Mode if you do not have Arcade
Mode don't worry the best of mode into
play is the new event game mode SSE knee
a Templar II I believe that is wrong but
doesn't matter it's the new event game
mode I ran this through a couple times
and managed to complete this in 6
minutes and then again in 9 minutes and
I managed to get 3 to 4 rewards per game
and as well there's a really easy tip to
actually exploit this which will show on
screen a shaman showed me this as I was
playing I had no clue this existed if
you are on the one side of the map and
you're attacking the other team I don't
even remember what the spawn names are
but there's two areas that you can
actually drop off the commander and
actually one shot him I'll show it on
now me and the shaman were pushing the I
believe it was a Zadeh
or Ezio off the map trying to throw him
off and it's a one-shot kill because
that is off the map
Ezio or wherever are Ezio was at this
time is a little bit harder you have to
drag him out to the outside of the
little area the he's in and then out by
the ladder or the ledges that one's
gonna be a little bit more difficult the
one that we were against is actually a
lot easier but you can cheese in this
way by dealing all sorts of damage
because it is a one shot and just
killing him instantly instead of
fighting him it's very cheesy but it
gets the game done very quickly and yeah
that's about it just to recap if you do
have Arcade Mode definitely utilize that
like I said I did provide a little bit
of a guide in how to beat these heroes
throughout the video and if you do and I
have Arcade Mode play the new event mode
do get about three to four rewards each
just remember to play an AI only and use
the exploit that me and that shaman
found out during our game by knocking
them off the ledge and one side of them
shouldn't be too difficult hey guys it's
gonna be the end of the visit hope you
guys did enjoy let me know what you guys
got so far out of the event so far I've
gotten a decent amount of rewards I've
gotten a decent amount of weapons as
well nothing too much for the battle
offered sadly although they do look
pretty cool I don't really care too much
so it's nothing big of a deal and as
well let me know how you guys like the
new assassin's creed event I think this
is a really cool event love the new
stuff that we're getting from this via
like the view if we do enjoy subscriber
for new I cover the informational sign a
foreigner that being balanced changes
here are updates patch notes of leaks as
well some guides like this so to keep
everyone up to date on the world of for
honor and what's happening within the
game my two most recent videos would be
on screen if you guys do want to check
that out when that guy so ever guys
today I think for watching the video
as we've always enjoy the event and
peace out guys
[Music]
you
[Music]